foreign
countries
then they start oppressing Us in France
especially if you are not African if you
came from if your forefathers are
chariots Moroccans tunisians
it's not hard for you
it's hard to find a job no doubt that's
why I love the man doing crimes and so
on because they see your name Muhammad
therefore the Stevie in the bin so they
oppressed for a long time and they
killed this young brother
or Precious too much people get up
explode instead however
however
as a Muslims
not to remove compression with
oppression
burning people's cars
welding their buildings burning the
police station that is incorrect
teaching
he said he was defending himself with a
young boy who is not doing nothing
out of nature
there is no doubt but however my dear
brothers and sisters should not remove
operational oppression we should not
abandon all countries
why are you gonna cause out other people
maybe the people that you've been in
their cars the unguards this police
official too
yes there is racism in front there's
oppression of many years
that happened to our brothers and
sisters in France in France you're
allowed to walk naked but to cover
yourself
that's crazy on the front he says
where's the freedom you're just a Liars
your biggest lies are like exposed you
especially ibrahimi when our school has
said he said
France is the biggest enemy against the
Muslims you know and look there's more
Muslim influence if I can be oppressed
subhanallah however we should not
few of them and Justice give them
Justice because there is French people
who are with the Muslims even they're
not the Muslims they help the Muslims
even maybe some of them working in the
government they want to help the Muslims
so my dear brothers and sisters that's
what protesting against it to begin with
is of the Islamic teaching there's other
ways however What's Happening Now
burning people's cars houses not
allowing people to come out that is not
a solution and yes if I'm sticking with
my desires I said let's do it but our
criteria our judge is
foreign